hi I'm anyway and I'm a mathematics
teacher so one of the things I think is
centrally important to mathematics and
in some ways makes it a little bit
unique from learning some of the other
subjects is that making mistakes is so
important in fact it's something which
we spend our lives kind of fleeing away
from we don't like the feeling of all I
know this got wrong this is you get big
red X's on it and that's not a fun
feeling we've got very strong emotional
connections to that but actually it's
vitally important for us to engage the
part of our mind and form sort of neural
connections there that are associated
with okay I made a mistake something has
gone wrong number one how did I know
that was wrong number two how do I back
myself out of that and then think about
this from another perspective in you
know multiple representation theater we
talked about the importance the
centrality of seeing one idea a single
concept from multiple different angles
and in fact we don't know something well
until we can see it from multiple
perspectives if you think for example of
seeing a shadow or something and it
looks rectangular you think okay well I
have an idea in my mind of what that
looks like and then you look at that
same object its shadow from a different
perspective realize it's a circle and
suddenly your brain kind of does this
there's this cognitive dissonance that
you experience when you realize oh this
doesn't fit what I thought it was before
and the idea of a cylinder now finally
emerges into your mind you're like oh
without having thought about this from
multiple perspectives I wouldn't have
arrived at that understanding so I think
it's really important that students and
teachers embrace the ability to say okay
maybe I got it wrong the first time
that's okay what can I learn from
looking at this another way
[Music]